okay and we are
live on linkedin as well so i want to
welcome
everyone to our career master class
topic today is
how to get the best job search result
from job boards our
guest today is carmen bryant
until recently as director of u.s
marketing at indeed
fortunately ever here today
um and i'll introduce carmen in just a
moment but first
a note about using the webex controls
answered questions for her in the
q a
box and we'll collect those and
pass those on during the q a portion of
the
presentation
toward the end
you can chat to all panelists
that but we may not be able to respond
immediately as we'll be in conversation
um we'll also have a few
polls during the
person of the presentation so the first
one is very straightforward
just how much work experience do you
have that'll give
permanent appreciation for who's in the
audience
um second part of the question is how
are you doing today we've been asking
this
throughout
the
course of the pandemic
just to check in on people
how they're dealing with surges coming
and going and rising and falling
about another 15 seconds to answer the
question
close the ball in five four
three
two
[Music]
one
and
here's the result
about half of our audience are people
with more than five years of experience
and the rest are evenly distributed
among
people between college university up to
five years of experience
so
it's kind of a diverse audience today
and
it's nice to see that about 90 percent
of everybody said that they were doing
well
um
we hope that what carmen has to share
with you today
will uh
prove your outlook if you're in that
other 10 so
with that said i'm going to
uh introduce carmen bryant who is the
former director of marketing us
marketing at indeed
um she's held strategic insight
positions for
companies like nbc universal which is a
major
film and broadcasting company
with global reach and
and many other top tier companies as
well and she's a graduate
of harvard university so um welcome
carmen
and uh
good morning good afternoon or good
evening to the folks on the call
depending on where you're
calling in from i'm super excited to be
here today
um
just to give you a little bit
more insight into my experience and
perhaps why i'm here today
is um as ford mentioned i was most
recently
the head of u.s marketing at indeed up
until march
um and like to think of myself as being
a free agent right now and going you
know starting to look at opportunities
like many of you on the call right now
and and during my time there you know i
did an array of different things but you
know we and myself included felt very
passionate about our mission of helping
people to get jobs
and one of the things i did quite a bit
was to
go out and talk to
companies about how to hire the best
talent
as well as as job seekers
a bit so it's exciting to be able to
share some of that with you
and um it was great for all of you to
share kind of your experience with me
stuart i don't think i even mentioned
that i'm actually getting over covet
right now oh no you didn't i can almost
uh hear a little touch of that in your
voice
yeah so i i think i'm gonna say i'm
doing pretty well but definitely better
than i was last week and i'm very oh my
gosh
sorry to hear that my daughter just got
over a mild battle cove yeah i mean i
think i got a little cocky i've been
enjoying my time off i was gallivanting
all over new york city which is where
i'm based
and um and so you know here we are but
but i'm quarantining and i'm healthy and
whole for the most part and able to
participate in this conversation
and i see there are some good wishes for
you to get well soon from the audience
so thank you thank you
um so
let's start off with a kind of a
straightforward question which is you
know what is the state of hiring right
now
yeah it's um
you know
i think there's a there's a few
different ways you can look at sort of
what's happening in hiring one is to
sort of look at you know the bureau of
labor statistics and and see what are
the
you know the the metrics
that are sort of like the indicators um
and indeed and a lot of this information
is published publicly um so you can get
access to it and indeed we were also
able to look at our own platform data
because to look at what was the volume
of postings that we have what is the
search activity
to really kind of understand what's
happening and i think that and that is a
pretty good time to be a job seeker
right now
um it is you know we're in a place where
demand
for workers far outstrips worker
readiness to accept roles and while
that's starting to uh modulate a little
bit
we're seeing that we're seeing wage
growth
has really increased
so it's not it's a pretty good time to
be to be looking for opportunities when
we look at
um
you know the job postings on our site
actually i think it would be interesting
to get a pulse from the audience because
we look at job postings on indeed
historically
and um i think it would be great this
would get a sense from the audience or
maybe what they think the state of
india's postings
are okay
and we've got that poll up
so
i mentioned that you know demand exceeds
supply
um and we can look at the number of
postings on our site relative to
pre-pending levels so how far above
pre-pandemic levels do you think
indeed's current job postings are
15 35
55
or 70 percent
and i got about
five more seconds
and we'll close the
polls and here's what the audience
thinks
so the majority is a pretty diverse 35
percent
about a quarter say either 55 or 15 and
16 say 70
the answer is actually 55
so the job postings on indeed
are approximately 55
above
our pre pandemic levels
so we
we were seeing and continue to see
um
that there's just so much demand for
workers right now
um so it's actually a pretty pretty good
time
to be looking for for opportunities
excellent um
so
what
if someone's out there looking for
opportunities
indeed being one of them what what are
the different kinds of tools that you
can use
when you're looking for a job what what
should you be using
yeah um you should be using probably as
many of them as possible but you know
for sure i have to talk about online job
boards
um and job boards job aggregators job
search engines
sometimes those are used in a chain
interchangeably and they are roughly you
know very similar they're a place where
you know companies go and post jobs
online
so that you can get access to new
opportunities you absolutely should be
using online job boards
um they are you know probably right now
the primary source of hiring from online
uh you know for online
uh but you also need to be thinking
about you know networking and
um you know social networks
um referrals referrals are
remain a huge way in which companies
find talent
you know i i think it's important you
know when i go talk to organizations one
of the things i talk about is in order
to make sure
that you are finding a diverse range of
potential candidates you don't want to
rely solely on referrals
because you end up hiring people that
are very similar to the people that you
already have
but you know 67 of employers still
consider referrals to be a primary way
to find talent
job fairs
especially online i think one of the
things that the pandemic really did is
it catalyzed innovation in the space
so
there are a lot of companies
there are a lot of
organizations like indeed and others
that are
doing online job fairs so that you know
you have the opportunity to
find those kinds of roles as well
and if there are companies that you have
your eye on of course go to their their
sites as well so
there's an array of different you know
ways but would certainly
you know you should be thinking about a
mix of those different opportunities or
those different resources
to find
um
the right opportunity
um
you talked about the
the pitfalls of referrals and and um
leading to a company of all the people
being the same
um there's an old quote from
david ogilvy who was
the
founder of juvian mathers one of the
greatest advertising agencies of the
20th century
and
what he would do is when he hired
someone new
he would send them a russian nesting
doll you open the doll and there's
another doll and you open the door when
you get to the final doll inside there
was a like a chinese fortune cookie
fortune and it said
if we hire people lesser than ourselves
we will become a company of midgets if
we hire people greater than ourselves we
will become a company of giants
so that was a
kind of a notion about you know the
the dangers of referrals being just oh
this is a great guy or a great
woman
it's really you're you still have to be
looking for
top talent when you're when you're
hiring so
the flip side of that for our job
seekers today on the on this call is
you know you need to be recognized as
top talent yeah absolutely i always used
to tell people i got my job at indeed on
indeed
um
and
um i met someone you know glassdoor was
a sister company and
there was someone at glassdoor it's like
i got my job at glass door on glass door
so it really goes to show
that you know it really does kind of
democratize access and opportunity
so it's really important i think to to
try to leverage it as much as possible
okay um so
when we look at job boards as one of the
tools what are the the benefits
of job boards
to job seekers
yeah you know i think there are some
obvious ones right like there's tons of
opportunities so you can go to
presumably
one
um or maybe just a handful of
destinations to find
really a wide range of potential roles
you're also going to be exposed to
what the latest opportunities are
and i can talk a little bit more and
i'll talk a little bit more about indeed
in a bit but you know i know and indeed
you know you can kind of prioritize
opportunities based on date or we would
sort of add additional visibility or or
share the roles that were posted in
their posting date just so you could get
a sense of
you know what those opportunities are
um i think one of the ways in which job
boards i think can be leveraged even
more
that they probably aren't as much is for
research
because there's such a wide
variety of different roles
so
it can include
you know researching companies for sure
you know most
have
you know very extensive research on all
the different companies especially if
they're large enterprise organizations
um they have them sort of um they have
their information on the site but you
can also
research the types of jobs that you
might be interested in if you think
you're interested in
you know being a marketing analyst or a
developer or
you know whatever the case may be
you can go and start to look at job
descriptions and understand
you know what are the
requirements for the role what are
organizations looking for
what is the gap between what i have and
maybe what these companies are looking
for so i think
leveraging them for research is a really
important benefit to using
a job board
you can also automate your search once
you've gotten to a place
where you
sort of have an idea of what you're
looking for and you started to test it
and get a sense of yes i'm getting the
right type of response now
you can automate
that job search so that jobs are coming
to you proactively
rather than you having to go
to the job board and the same thing goes
for the application process you know
indeed for example has an easy apply
option
so that you can fairly easily apply to
rules through form
um and you know many other
platforms do as well so those are those
are some of the benefits i think of
using an online job board
and just to be clear because we had a
question from the audience the job board
is a is a
industry term for
an online
job listing job search
platform and it's not
specific to indeed or glassdoor or
any of the other individual platforms
right correct it's an industry term and
um
you know so
there are platforms like glassdoor that
might be known a little bit more for
reviews but they also have a job board
component similarly through linkedin
they're known more i would say it's more
of a professional social networking and
content site but there is a job board
component but
um
you know also some of the historical
sort of job board i shouldn't say
historically still exist but like
career builder
um
which are kind of the more traditional
sort of ways that we think of of of job
boards
and and
you know a number of people in our
audience are in india there are a number
of india
country specific job boards or job
boards that started and are based in
india that have moved global so um it's
uh not great
yeah so that's a a big player
in in india um as well and i believe
they are like expanding globally
yeah it's it's pretty amazing um
simply learn as a company that's based
in
bangalore we're not a job board we're an
education platform and
but we're expanding globally as well and
it's it's pretty amazing what the the
technology opportunities are it really
has so if anything i think the pandemic
in a lot of ways also made the world
it made it both smaller and larger you
know people were separated and unable to
get home but with everybody working
remotely all of a sudden
you know we are
really kind of made it clear how to work
in a global sort of economy
exactly um
so
you talked about you know the advantages
of using a job board what should people
look out for what are the kinds of
pitfalls that can happen
when they start a job or you know using
job boards for their for their job
search what should they be wary of
yeah i think one of the things you know
and this might be a little bit more
relevant for the folks that are
you know have a bit more experience but
i think you have to be
cognizant of the fact that job boards
are listing the latest opportunities
but as we know there are opportunities
that are arising constantly that have
yet to be posted
and so
you want to be conscious of the fact
that and certainly for maybe some senior
level positions rescue you know go up
and experience
um it's important to
continue to build your network and think
about referrals
because it really will enable you to
have insight into opportunities
that are
you know
not even on the job force yet
so i think that's important i think the
other thing to consider is that
to sort of understand a bit of how
search works
and
how these different job boards serve up
content to you so i'll talk a little bit
about indeed
okay and i'll share a little bit about
some you know personal experience
so
indeed as a job search engine it has an
algorithm
that really enables
the platform to serve up the jobs that
are the most relevant to you
often based on what you searched for
previously
so
if you are someone who's really junior
in your career
and you don't really know what you want
to do
and this is an actual sort of you know
real data point
um they have a tendency to put blank
like in indeed the the search engine is
a what and where box what do you want to
do and where do you want to do it people
would often leave the what block box
blank
and then
put in new york city for the wear box or
bangalore india for the wear box
now because of
the
you know algorithm we know that that 10
sweet people that are more junior
and so therefore they are probably going
to be served up jobs like customer
service rep or retail sales associate
um but we also know that sometimes
people that really senior levels of the
organization might do that as well so if
they are
in the c-suite level because they've
kind of gotten to a certain place in
their career and maybe they're not
necessarily
looking exclusively for a ceo job but
they're trying to find a senior level
position in a certain market
um
you know hopefully that executive has
been engaging with that platform before
so they would have a sense of what
they're sort of like doing
but if it defaults right it could serve
up
you know potentially some opportunities
that are not what you're interested in
um so i think it's just really important
to keep in mind that on indeed it's
going to be based on
your activity on that
site
i was just going to comment on that is
that um
this is something that's
more prevalent from
years past but
sometimes you have a senior executives
who haven't
been in the job market per se for a
while
and they're not really familiar with how
a job board works and so
it's kind of like
what am i going to do here and like you
said if you put in
blank assuming that you're going to get
all of the potential jobs that are
suited to you
you're not really using that platform
properly because it doesn't necessarily
know that you know you spent 20 years as
the
you know chief operating officer or ceo
of a company so absolutely yeah that's a
that's a big thing if you're helping
someone else search for a job right i
mean there there could be some reasons
or rationale as to why you know or
you're deciding to change careers now
granted you have the what box but you
might need to spend a little bit more
time being more thoughtful initially
to think about how do i want to sort of
build this query
um recently you know i learned similarly
on linkedin linkedin has a ton of
information right about you it has
your
your network it has if you're posting
content
so linkedin tends to serve up jobs
and content but jobs and content where
it is there
it's when it's connected to people in
your network
so if you have
you know if you work in tech and you're
interested in going into a different
industry altogether
um you're need to sort of acknowledge
the fact that you might be getting
opportunities served up
that are
more aligned to your current network
because those are all the connections
that you have
so i think it's important to understand
um just a little bit of how search works
and how the algorithms generally
speaking
are being used and to take that into
consideration
um on your behavior on the platform or
in
you know doing your job search
that makes sense because you don't want
to have the the job board itself the
algorithms
pigeonhole you um
unreasonably i mean you
it's great if it's
looking at your skills your network your
experience and saying
this is a great job for you based on all
of that but
then if you're if you're really looking
to pivot to a new
field and a lot of our
a lot of the people who work with uh or
come to simply learn are looking to
pivot into a new technology or a new
field um you don't want
to let the algorithm restrict you or
act as a gatekeeper to block you out of
that absolutely i
um i'm on linkedin fairly
often and so i've spent you know six
years in tech but i also spent a decent
amount of time in media
i was just you know
sort of curious as to why like so much
of my content and you know interactions
are in the tech space as opposed to
media
um and and that's what what i came to
understand so
um so for sure you know be be thoughtful
about that and sort of understand that
yeah
um
can you
kind of discuss with the audience what
are some of the best practices that they
should use when they're going to indeed
or
any of the other job boards what are the
what are the steps they should take and
the things they should be mindful of to
get the best result
sure and um i'll i'll you know lean a
little bit more heavily on indeed
because that's you know where my
experience sort of lies but um i would
imagine that this is applicable for for
many
uh different types of job boards uh the
first thing is to create an account
i mean i know that sounds like a um
kind of like a no-brainer but
that is one how they start to build a
profile on who you are
often i know on indeed for example
um you know we're not capturing like
demographic information it's your name
and an email address right
so you don't have to worry about too
much of that information being out there
but as you start to
sort of have different activity on the
site
you'll start to see that
you know your job results come back a
little bit more personalized you also
will have an opportunity to get
typically free personalized resources as
a result of that
and i know for sure on
indeed there are resources that exist
for
job seekers that are for free
uh similarly for linkedin
um so you know creating an account
creating a uh that's the first step
setting up your profile
you know or your resume
depending on you know what site you're
on
you want to make sure
that
you're doing that on indeed
one of the things to
understand when you create and upload
your resume
is that you're going to have two
different options you can set it to
private or you can set it to public
right and that is because there is
you know we want to make sure that we
are protecting job seekers privacy so if
you set it to private you'll have it on
the site
if you want to easily apply to a role
with one click you can do that
but no one would be able to search your
resume
if you send it to public
that means that when recruiters or
companies are looking for talent
and they go and they search
you know for
software developers
in san francisco
then you will
come up in their search results now even
with that on indeed for example
your contact information is not provided
because often on our resume our contact
information is you know included
so
they will reach out to you and
essentially what indeed will do is
broker a communication
once you say yes
that is when that recruiter or hiring
manager is given your contact
information and can contact you and
there are a lot of ways that indeed
really tries to promote thoughtful
curated
messages
um because we want people to respond
even if the response is negative
right so that you know the same way we
don't want companies to lead job seekers
kind of in a black hole
you know we want to sort of ensure that
you know job seekers are getting an
outreach that you know compels them to
respond
even if the response is you know no
thank you
um
so that's something else to to take note
of
um the other thing i would say is
you know we often tell people to think
like an employer
when they are
you know looking for job opportunities
and i think that this is when the
research
can really come into play
you know if you are
looking for a retail
sales associate job
right you probably want to
make sure that it's communicated that
you
live close by or that it won't be a
problem for you to
sort of get to
wherever it is you're going
if you are a registered nurse
and the role is for
you know an er nurse right be really
explicit about that in your job search
so that you are pulling up those
opportunities so really think about
the filters
and the different ways that you can
you know hone in on your search
so that you can make it as relevant to
you as possible
but also
to the employer
um so i think that's that's something to
keep in mind and kind of along those
same lines is
you know think about how to highlight
your skills
uh any you know upskilling that you've
done any assessments
that you've taken um
you know indeed has a plethora of
assessments i know
simply learn of course is an educational
platform so you're providing ways for
people to sort of educate themselves
another way to make yourself stand out
from the crowd because i think one of
the things
that most organizations are looking for
i would imagine this is somewhat of a
blanket statement
but people who are
self-motivated and curious
and
when you are sort of you know
making an effort to continue to hone
your skills and
do assessment that certainly suggests
that you know you are someone who is
self-motivated and curious especially in
a remote world
you know i used to be a hiring manager
and i had people who were in office
before the pandemic
people were in office versus people who
were
you know remote and in the field
and now everybody is but during that
time
i learned a lot about
you know what it means for someone to be
sort of self-motivated and self-directed
and proactive
and it's really important i think in a
remote world
to be able
to to really demonstrate that um
there used to be something called
management by walking around
which was
which was which was a uh a term that got
popularized in the 1980s from uh
from the book uh
practices of
uh
the title the exact title escapes me but
it was very famous management book but
one of the things was management by
walking around where if you're a manager
you should walk through the areas where
your employees work and not just sit in
your office because you'll pick up a lot
of information
yeah
the problem in the postpandect world is
you
can't walk around
yeah yeah you can't just
kind of look over the shoulder of
somebody who's working at home because
they control that interaction and so
um you really have to
like you said
look for people
and if you're
an employee to be
a person
who
[Music]
demonstrates that they
take responsibility for their own work
that they
direct a lot of their own activity
that if they're given a task they
pursue it and don't need to be
monitored closely so because
those opportunities for managers to do
those things are much less than they
were in the pre-pandemic world
yeah you know and and you know along
those lines and the conversations that
you know i would have with companies
there was definitely an increased
interest on
sort of like some of those soft skills
right like obviously to have those hard
skills
typically is you know
we want to be able to sort of have
someone if you're a software developer
you have to be able to code like those
are things that are just must-haves
but some of those soft skills that you
know you and i are talking about about
the way in which you actually do your
work
often is harder to assess and so
being able to demonstrate that in an
objective way
is is really important and
you know we heard so many companies say
like i can't i can no longer manage
output right it's not just about like
you have to do
70 sales calls in a week it had to be
based on impact or a body of work
right not just activity
so that is changing a bit
of how
organizations are trying to find talent
i think it's important for
job seekers to understand that
for sure
one thing i can i'll tell a story on
myself um
one thing you need to be aware of when
you're using job boards is what happens
after you get a job
because i had actually found
a job uh
this
current position was simply learned
through through a job board and
um i had been working several months
and
everything was going great and my boss
who happened my
local boss happens to be two levels
above me in the organization called me
up and i said i have a question for you
um are you looking for another job and i
said
oh i'm extremely happy here
um
well you know you're on a job board
somewhere it's like oh i'd forgotten to
take down
that listing so it's one of those things
is that you you do want to be you know
careful
that you practice you know good hygiene
so to speak and
cut down that job search when you're
done with it and put it on a different
level if you're
interested i mean one of the things that
job boards
can do as you've pointed out is
they can leave your information out
there in a way that employers can notify
you through the job board about
opportunities you hadn't heard of or you
weren't actually looking for and you
might be interested in one of those so
you might not want to say
okay i'm i'm not looking
i don't want any contact at all
you might want to get those those
notifications but you want to do it in a
way that your current employer
doesn't think you're still looking for
another job right
yeah
no that's that's so true and you know
our some of the research that i did in
indeed we found that
most people leave a job when they are a
either disillusioned with their current
sort of opportunity or b when they're
inspired by a new opportunity
and a big source of that inspiration
would come from
you know people who set up job alerts
got a job forgot about it and then all
of a sudden this opportunity appears in
their inbox or they get outreach from
someone
and there's this new opportunity so
it can be it can be nice as you said to
have that
so that you know you are sort of staying
abreast of what's happening
but it can also result in you know i you
know i have to say the same thing
happened to me it wasn't so much my
employer but you know i would get calls
for jobs that i think i would have been
qualified for like 10 years ago or five
years
and it's like why are you asking about
this now i posted my resume like years
ago
so that's another reason to practice
you know really good hygiene
um i'll also just sort of like reiterate
again the importance of understanding
you know keywords and how to how to use
those so when you go and you research
companies
um and you are interested in
you know say a software engineering or
you know i'll say marketing that's just
close to me you're interested in a
marketing manager role
and you go and you look at the different
profiles and you notice or job
descriptions so you notice that
digital marketing is something that's
really important or they want to know
a lot of people are asking if you know
about google adwords or if you have
experience with crms
you want to take those keywords that are
drivers
of those job descriptions and
incorporate them into your resumes
because
when recruiters are screening for
resumes
they
are likely gonna be
doing it
you know with an eye to what the needs
for that role is so i'm gonna like do
our second poll here because i think it
would be interesting to sort of get a
take from people on
what is the average amount of time a
recruiter spends
screening
a resume
is it seven seconds 33 seconds two
minutes or five minutes
take a look
and we'll give you about another
five seconds
here is the result
okay
uh about
40 percent say 7 32 2 minutes five
minutes um well you are correct
they spend seven seconds
screening your resume
now it's important that i use the word
screening
but this is the part of the process when
they've posted that job description
they are starting to get resumes
and they are trying to cut it down from
what might be a larger number to more
manageable numbers of resumes that they
know are going to be qualified
they're going to give each of those
resumes about seven seconds
so you want to make sure that you have
you know
like some key information
included on that resume
um now the hope you know this might not
always be the case but the hope is that
once they have it down to a more
manageable number and they are starting
to sort of potentially call people in
for interviews or do a little bit more
you know
in-depth sort of assessments that
they'll spend a little bit more time but
that initial screen is going to be seven
seconds so make it as easy as possible
for them to be able to decide that you
are in fact the right candidate for that
role i i have a question relating to
that um
what's your take on
the fact that that first screen may be
occurring through an ai bot
yeah that is um that is an interesting
point i mean i think in some ways you
know
it might
i would think that a lot of it would
still apply in a lot of ways so if you
are a you know software engineer
typically what happens and you know i am
not an expert when it comes to ai
but typically what they're doing is like
they're using sort of
historical information
to assess future sort of you know um
sort of um alignment or whatever the
right word is
so based on what they know to be true
which is that the software developers
that we've hired in the past
have these skills
they would use that to sort of determine
whether or not your arrest may fit into
that now ai is interesting and there's a
whole area of ai called ai ethics yes
important because
we know you know garbage and garbage out
because if you are a company that has
historically always hired people from
harvard university for example
when a resume comes through that has
harvard university it might pluck it out
as being particularly relevant
when that obviously is not the sole
indicator as to whether or not someone
is in the role so
there's definitely a lot of
consideration
that companies are making at least smart
progressive companies are making on how
to ensure that the ai is actually doing
the job they need in terms of
bringing
highly qualified people into the fold
but not sort of extending existing bias
so i think that is a really interesting
question it is an interesting question
that's being discussed
certainly in the world of you know tech
and hr tech in particular
um
now you touched on a notion of
extracting keywords from
job descriptions
and feeding those back into your resume
and
one thing i would point out about that
is
you need to be
sure that when you take that keyword
that
it's something you know how to do before
you put it into your resume
yes
and and the
extension to that is
if you notice that there's a
job category that you're very interested
in and you keep seeing these keywords
come up in the job descriptions but you
are not yet familiar with how to do that
um you know one of the things you can do
is to look to a company like simply
learn to gain that skill
so that when you do add it to your
resume you can legitimately say yes i
have been trained in this i do have
projects i've done that i can show you
so
that's that's an aspect of
making sure that your skills are up to
date making sure that their skills are
wanted in the marketplace and making
sure that your skills are sharp that you
know when somebody says you must
demonstrate it
that you're able to do that um which
leads to another question which is you
know what are the the most in demand
jobs now and what are they projected to
be in the next
uh coming year or two oh sure um and
stuart thank you so much for for adding
that yeah please please
use it as a guide but be completely
honest
and decide you know how to sort of like
you know hone your skills uh it was
interesting to me like i thought this
was you know an important thing to talk
about you know as we talked about jobs
and you know i'm going to go back to our
earlier question about some of the
pitfalls around job boards because
as i started to do a bit of research
around this i noticed that depending on
the job board you went to
you might get a slightly different
answer and i think that has to do with
the folks that are coming to the site so
um taking that into
consideration and looking around and
just sort of like my experience over the
past
two years
uh during the pandemic in particular
um
the areas that are in demand right now
there are there are a couple that are
just you know seem to be evergreen right
so
you know engineering roles developer
rural roles data scientist roles
uh those kind of technology roles are
really
um in demand
um the interesting thing about them is
that more and more companies are
eliminating
uh college degree requirements
for
those types of roles because you can
objectively
you know identify whether or not someone
is good at coding
and you know whether it's boot camps or
assessments or other kinds of training
programs that they do
so
there's a great demand for that and
there's a lot of opportunity for someone
as we mentioned who's self-motivated
um to to go in that arena because you
know
indeed for example you know eliminated
the college degree requirement for that
um
not surprisingly certainly here in the
u.s
nurses and registered nurses are really
hot and
you know
hard hard job
but for the people that i know who were
in nursing during the pandemic and who
were able to kind of persevere
there was certainly considerable
sort of financial upside to do
my wife is a registered nurse and she
works as a telephone triage nurse which
means she's working from home
answering questions on the telephone but
it's
a
short staffed field so
he's
doing very well financially so yeah and
it was you know
it was nursing was like that before the
pandemic it was always a field in which
there was not enough supply
for the demand and so the pandemic
really just kind of exacerbated that
um and so along those lines right now
you know not surprisingly frontline
workers so things in the healthcare
fields things in retail
uh truck drivers you know certainly in
the states
is really um
another big area
of rules that are in demand so i would
say
you know technology and health care
uh again exacerbated by the pandemic
because people are working remote things
are moving online
um and we need health care workers and
we need frontline workers now that
doesn't mean that those are the only
things like interestingly sales
is an area
where there's a lot of need sales and
kind of like customer service type roles
um
so
you know there's there's a lot of demand
in in those spaces right now
um when we think about sort of the
future
of of jobs
um you know i would think about and i i
would imagine technology
is going to continue to be
sort of an in-demand role
um healthcare
um in addition to nurse you know nurse
registered nurses think about nurse
instructors
nurse practitioners yes absolutely
anything that's going to help alleviate
kind of
the burdens that we're facing in the
healthcare industry right now
um industries that are around climate
change
um
are becoming are sort of like projected
to be
kind of increasingly important whether
it's roles that are around wind energy
or solar energy
um
you know in an array of different fields
there are a number of people that i know
that have gone to work for
green energy companies
um
so
you know well i think we'll continue to
see many of the roles now
that are in demand continue to be in
demand but also think about you know
climate change
um mental health
is going to be i think a pretty big
field as well there's
so much more of a focus on
mental well-being and workplace
well-being so i think there's going to
be huge opportunities there
yeah
especially as you mentioned mental
health it's becoming
a recognized crisis in a lot of
environments and a lot of countries
that
the
stresses that we've been through in the
pandemic
have
just aggravated the the
difficulties that people have had with
mental health so that's that's an area
where
there's going to be much more
emphasis in spending and hiring so
that's a great a great catch um
i'd say this one last thing that i
wanted to mention and forgot as you're
researching companies and i'll talk
about indeed here a bit too
when you research companies on indeed
they are given a rating
um and
on a scale of like one to five i believe
and so if a company if you go to indeed
and a company has a score of 4.3 or
higher that is considered really really
good
if a company has a floor that's also
good but i just wanted to point that out
and then in
2020 we also launched a workplace
well-being score so you can also go and
kind of see
how a company is stacking up based on
you know stress level
you know trust
um a sense of belonging
a sense of diversity like those kinds of
things so
other things to keep in mind as you're
researching and trying to get a sense
potentially of what your overall
well-being might be working in an
organization
okay
um i think this is an opportune time for
us to move on to the q a
that's all right with you absolutely so
we've got a number of uh
questions in from the audience we won't
have time to take them all but
um
i do want to start off
um
here's a question that i'm sure is on
the mind of a number of people in our
audience which is how can a
non-us resident get
either a work permit to work in the u.s
or
access to remote work in the us
yeah i mean that's a interesting
question and i feel like it's a bit
challenging because it's probably going
to differ company by company now in
terms of
um and i think the easiest route is
probably to work remote
for a company based in the us
um and
one way might be to see if there's an
organization that has offices already
in
um in your in your country because
one of the challenges for u.s markets is
often tax
for tax reasons
so they are
um
you know certainly some of the larger
organizations are really strategic about
making sure that they are hiring people
in
locations where they have you know
permission to do business and are paying
taxes so if they have employees of some
sort
operating in that country
then that sort of bodes well
the other thing that i would say is that
more and more companies are starting to
try to open their borders as much as
possible now some of that is you know
going to be within reason
um but i think just because of demand
for talent
is probably a you know one of the better
times in history right to be in this
position
um so i would think if you have you know
a short list of companies
that you're thinking about kind of you
know researching them and understanding
their approach to hiring
is another way to look at it and then on
a lot of sites
you can also search for remote anywhere
in the world like it'll say remote
and location remote in the us or remote
anywhere in the world and so that's
another
search term you can use when you are
doing your search so that's kind of the
last bit of advice there and that
answers essay's question which is you
know your two platforms limit users by
geographic location so
yeah
i mean some of them do and so that's
important because if you are searching
for
now
if you're searching for jobs
say in the u.s you're going to be taken
to the u.s platform but if i want to go
to the canada platform it's
indeed.ca or if i want to go to the uk
platform it's indeed.co.uk
so you might have to get a little little
clever but i think you can do it and i
would still in all those situations
search you know remote anywhere in the
world
um
so
you touched a little bit on the kinds of
services that a job board can give to
people who create an account use that
job board
and i'm wondering if this question
relates to that so navin
um
has had a lot of interviews but he
hasn't succeeded in getting that job
is
one of the services that
indeed provides or
job boards in general
is that
help or pointing people to help with
resume building
interview training things like that
where where would they go for that yes
yes to that question
um so on indeed there's a site that's
just career advice
and you can go and it will have examples
of cover letters examples of resumes
so you can kind of access information
that way
indeed also has an interview not an
interview a resume review service
which is um
is a fairly
you know nominal cost but basically a
professional
will review your resume and i think
there's you know a fairly like you know
maybe it's like i'm gonna mess up the
number so i don't want to say anything
but it's a pretty you know small amount
of money so
you can leverage
um you know
written career advice you can offer this
paid service there's also
jobcast
that indeed does on like facebook live
where they will also go through a lot of
this
linkedin you know since i no longer work
for indeed i can be as objective as
possible linkedin also has great
resources in this capacity where they
will
you know serve up you know job interview
questions and we'll do various trainings
uh so that you can optimize you know
your resume and your your interview
skills
putting a plug-in for simply learning a
number of our programs not all of them
but a number of our programs include a
job assist
so that
the resume building the interview
training
and um
job board membership
are all included in that
we have a couple of programs that we're
starting to do in
technology in software development
and in
data science where
we've teamed up with a number of
employers can actually offer a job
guarantee to people who can complete
those programs but those are
uh those are new those only apply to a
couple of fields so far so um
but
we've got
what would you offer to gohan who has an
engineering background he has an mba
and he wants to pivot into blockchain
and finance
so what kind of a strategy how can he
how can he use
um
these search tools his job search tools
to uh position himself into this new
field
yeah and you know i'll be really
transparent i mean you know blockchain
and you know that is not my area of
expertise
um so this will be you know advice that
i would give to
um
someone who is pivoting any career which
is to kind of leverage the process that
we talked about which is getting really
clear on
sort of what kind of the requirements
are potentially for the role that you
want to do
um in this case i would think a lot more
about transferable skills
and how what you've done
is going to
one yes enable you to do the job but to
bring a fresh perspective that is going
to add value
to the future of whatever organization
that you're looking at so i think in
your case
it's going to be a mix of
yes you want to make sure that you have
the base level of requirements and you
might need to think about leveraging
simply learn or
you know thinking about those
transferable skills
but i think in your case you're also
gonna
need to be proactive in writing your
narrative because it's not just about
like if i'm trying to go from a
marketing director to a marketing
director
um the need to do that is this great
but if i'm going from say a marketing
director to a sales director
then what i'm going to need to do is to
be able to have a narrative as to why
me
in this role as a marketing director is
going to be so beneficial
to this role as a sales director and
it's going to help the future of this
company this role or whatever the case
may be so get really clear on
you know
another marketing work what your value
prop is and your uniqueness
i think
could be
why you get the new opportunity
yeah and and
it's interesting in the specific case
you've got a
candidate who's got an engineering
background so the technology
the ability to pick up the technology
aspects of blockchain should be
fairly straightforward an mba background
so the ability to
understand the finance domain should be
fairly straightforward so that that
should be a strong
foundation for making that kind of a
pivot um
from tamil nadu says that
how can he research
industry standard
pay levels
so what are some of the tools that are
out there for looking at
you know typical salaries average
salaries that type of thing
i mean there is quite a move in the us
for
you know salary transparency
so on indeed
most i say 80 of jobs
have salaries attached to them and there
is a
an area where you can just go and search
salaries
so
indeed is certainly a great source
that's the one that i'm most familiar
with because i know that you know
so many of the roles do have salary
attached
and it is becoming increasingly
more common for you know certain states
to kind of legislate that it be provided
so you know
i would say start with indeed there's
there's definitely a few others out
there
but i know that indeed because it's so
big
uh 250 million people come every month
um and there's one and a half million
companies you know hiring on indeed at
any given time
um there's a lot of data so i think
that's a really good place to start
yeah and and as opposed to for example
linkedin has a lot of information about
jobs but it doesn't
it doesn't um
deal in
salaries as much so
it might be better for different
qualities of
you know researching careers um
how important are premium accounts
uh in online job boards is it is it
valuable
to pay for a premium account or is that
even something that happens on
well that doesn't happen on indeed so
for sure you wouldn't need to pay unless
you i think the the resume review
service i mentioned is the first time
we've ever done anything paid for the
job seeker
so not the case um
for
linkedin i mean i think it really
depends i think the benefits of doing a
premium
account on linkedin is that it will
enable you to reach out to people who
you might not have a direct connection
with that's right i think based on who
you're trying to reach and
you know like if you are someone who
maybe is trying to get into blockchain
and you don't know a lot of people who
are in that
maybe it is you know a useful you know
you know leverage of my you know way to
use money but uh i think it really
depends but i think that's that's
primarily the benefit um
um
how would a person a fresher who's got
you know just out of school
uh how would they
get past that seven second screening
process what are the what are the tips
that you'd offer to somebody in that
position
to make sure that
they get through that that first barrier
yeah i think it's two things i think one
is to research like research research
research research the role you want know
what you want to do know why you're good
at it so get tight on
like
what you're looking for
and then two
research the company in that role really
really well so that you can
make sure that your resume is really
built for
the position that you're looking for and
presumably if you are
more junior in your career you're going
to be looking for opportunities that are
more junior as well you know so
the competitive landscape should be
you know
appropriate
um but i think the research piece
because i think this idea of being able
to send out a resume to 200 companies
you're never going to get noticed
you need to get a little bit more
strategic and if you have to do
two different resumes three different
resumes so that they are
more customized to the role and or
industry you're interested in
that's what you have to do but i think
what separates people
is really the research in terms of of
what they are trying to do
um so we're running a little over time i
don't want to
keep you
longer and i do apologize to everyone
whose questions we could not get to
but um
i'm going to move on to our last poll
here and this is a
poll for our audience based on
the interests you have
just ask this question
no
so the two parts of the question are
what are the
subjects or or topics within technology
that you might be interested in
so that's what simplylearn does is
digital skills
and related skills
um and if you're interested in one or
more of these topics when do you want to
start learning
so i'll leave that open for a few more
seconds
and
here's the
result of the poll
so it's a pretty even distribution of
all the different
subject areas
with a little bit
more of the audience interested in
business and project management skills
and
surprisingly fewer
interested in software
um
and it's good to see about
a third or more of the audience is
interested in getting started right away
so
we will talk a little bit about that but
what i wanted to do now
is to
point out some resources
that
carmen has
collected here for you and i'm going to
put the
list here from the screen into the chat
window so that
folks can just copy and paste those and
look at these at their leisure
so let me get that in here
and
there in the chat window are these three
resources that you can look at
there's also carmen's
linkedin which i will also put into the
chat window and i want to thank
thank you carmen for being here today i
mean this is
this has been an excellent excellent
session
and a lot of people have said that
they've
learned a lot and it's been helpful and
again for the people whose
questions we couldn't get to i apologize
but we'll try to
do some of those offline but
um
again carmen thank you so much
absolutely thank you and and good luck
to everyone and i hope that you learned
something so uh so
hopefully we'll all get our dream jobs
right
um now i mentioned that we have the
resources available to people and
one of the resources that
simply learn offers is
skill up which is a free program
no charge for taking skill up courses
their self-study and they will give you
certificates in different skills
so
these are
entry-level courses and
things that act as a stepping stone to
get you into
new technology areas and
if you succeed at those you might be
interested in taking some of our more
advanced
courses with live virtual classrooms but
that link is in the chat window again
and
i will also mention that tomorrow and
thursday we have
additional
webinars in our series
these happen to be
topic
specific or domain specific one is on
software engineering which is a
demonstration of how to use angular and
spring boot
to build a
hr application and on thursday digital
marketing
on link building for
digital marketing so those
are also in the chat window the links
will take you directly to the
registration page
so
with that bit of advertising done i want
to thank again
uh carmen and and all of you in the
audience for being here i invite you to
follow us on our
social channels at simply learn facebook
and twitter simply learn on linkedin
and we hope to see you at future simply
learn webinars and we would love to
welcome you into the simply learn
learning community
so good luck to everybody thank you
you